these 25 years have cast some long
shadows but shadows have never seen
unless the sun is shining
our film memories would mean far less
where Hollywood not so brightly aglow
tonight
five outstanding motion pictures have
been nominated as the best films of 1952
here to make the presentation it's a
lady so well known as a fan so well
because Academy Award
well Mary how do you like our birthday
cake how does it look wonderful Bob
simply wonderful well it should you
poured the batter for that cake you put
the first icing on it and now it's up to
you to light up this year's candle the
25th by announcing the best picture of
the year those nominated for the Best
Motion Picture are the greatest show on
earth the male Paramount's Cecil B
DeMille High Noon Kramer United Artists
Stanley Kramer Ivanhoe MGM pandro s
Burman Moulin Rouge
Romulus United Artists the quiet man
Argosy Republic John Ford and Marion see
Cooper the winner is
Cecil B DeMille
married to take this from from you means
a great deal to me
you remember we were juveniles together
and Velasco Wanda Virginia just about
the time Nora started that craft I
forgotten what it was
hide me while I breed my long white
beard on behalf of the thousands that it
took to make the greatest show on earth
I thank you for them for the stars and
the electricians for the circus people
for their bravery it was a very
thrilling thing to see stars like Betty
Hutton and Gloria Grahame and Cornel
Wilde and Jimmy Stewart and Chuck Heston
those people risked their lives as did
the thousands of others who were in the
circus and the audience's all through
the trip I I thank you for all of them
because I am only one little link in a
in a chain that produced that picture
and I'm very happy for them
Thank You insensibly tomorrow miss Mary
Pickford there are folks all 25 candles
on the cake lift all we have to do now
is sit down and have a slice what a
silver jubilee